hello everyone today my channel hit
20,000 subscribers and I didn't really
have time to think of any type of
giveaway so I will think one tomorrow
and if any of you have any suggestions
for a giveaway please do share in the
comments you know to help me out and
well I'm glad that most of you enjoyed
my previous video and that immortal game
adventure played against Kasparov in
1991 linearis tournament and as I did
mention in that video that Magnus
Carlsen did have some unpleasant
encounters with vastly von Schuch as
hello he lost both games in 2016 world
blitz championship and also in 2016
world rapid championship and well he
also lost the game to event choke in
2015 and blitz championship and this is
the game I will show you as I think it's
it's the most interesting one and it has
the most dramatic ending as I will put
the video in description below where you
can check it out as you can see in the
quote about above the above the board in
the video Magnus Carlsen said can't win
them all apparently it's what Magnus
Carlsen tweeted after losing that game
and well it's it's what a dramatic game
like I said this is the world with
championship in 2015
Magnus Carlsen is white and Wesley von
Schuch is black so let's see this game
we have d4 by Carlsen Knight to f6
Bishop to g5 Magnus Carlsen goes for the
Trump off ski attack we have c5 Bishop
captures on f6g captures on f6 and d5
and okay Carlson decided to give
advantage of the bishop pair and let's
see how a von Schuch uses it it might
replace Queen to b6 already an
interesting move as he's attacking this
b2 pawn and white can defend this maybe
play B 3 and then c4 but maybe black
would have too much after after putting
this Bishop on g7 I'm assuming this
great diagonal so Carson plays Queen to
c1 and here we have again a very
interesting move by bunch of people is
f5 and this f5 is a very strong
especially for a blitz game as he is
preparing Bishop to g7 but also would
have five his preparing a very strong
outpost for his night here on e4 after
Knight to d7 to f6 to e4 we have C 4 by
Carlsen b6 Knight to c3 and 937 a von
Schuch moves on with his plan
we have g3 Bishop to g7 Knight to f3
Knight to f6 so moving on with the plan
Knight d2 and Carson is now protecting
this efore squared twice with both
nights but Avant you nevertheless place
nights to e4 so we have 9 TD captures on
e 4f captures on e4 and now well Carson
can't capture this pawn yet as if Knight
character spawned and this one here is
hanging so either Queen captures
probably Queen captures and b2 but also
Bishop captures on b2 as possible so
after F captures any four-cross and
played a bishop to g2 attacking that
point one more time and here Avant
replace Queen to b4 and he's attacking
this c4 pawn it it's well cousin can't
defend this pawn as b3 is impossible
since Knight would be hanging so Carson
castles and you want to capture the
point we camped Queen captures on c4 we
have Bishop captures on e4 and we have
h5 by von Schuch as well this King and
g1 is somewhat vulnerable now as this H
point is ready to ram this King site
castle we have h before by cost and
stopping this and Bishop to g4 now
attacking this upon AE to point Weiss
rook to e1 defending and a queenside
castle by von Schuch and rock to be one
Carson is ready to push we have King to
b8
bishop - G - now this night can move as
it's no longer obligated to defend the
bishop on e4
we have rook H to g8 Queen to e3 and
Bishop to f6 defending this e 7 pawn
cross in place nice to e4 and we have
Bishop to d4 now getting the bishop out
of the way and also attacking the Queen
Queen to d2 by Carlsen and now Quinn
casters on a2
a bunch of snatches this pawn and he
doesn't mind opening up the a file for
the ropes so we have Queen to f4 now
attacking that f7 pawn and here probably
probably Avant you could have captured
this d5 pawn and allow Queen captures on
f7 but he decided to play rook g 2f 8 we
have V 4
Costin is ready to open up the position
but we have Bishop to e5 attacking the
Queen Queen to b3 and now C for not
allowing to open up this B file and now
we have Knight to c3 with an attack on
the Queen we have Queen to a6 and now
Queen to d2 Brooke the c8 by a van truck
and III we have Bishop to f5 attacking
the rook now rook to a-1 we're gonna
tack on the Queen Queen to b6 now
attacking this b4 pawn and crossing
plays rook to a for defending the b4
pawn and also preparing to double up on
the a file we have Bishop to d3 already
that's a very nice bowing constant the
cousins throat and rook 8 you look II 2
a1 so doubling up at the a file and
preparing row captures an a7
eventually defense this upon to a6 and
we have Bishop to f3 and the Carson
wants to play Bishop to e2 and exchange
this very strong bishop on b3 but even
Chuck sets up a trap he plays Rock to g8
and the world this is a very nice trap
for Blitz game as if Carson would
continue with this plan of Bishop to e2
he would get rook captures and g3 and
this is this is deadly black is winning
here if F captures and g3 then Bishop
captures on c3 and cousin cannot capture
this Bishop as if Queen captures Bishop
then Queen captures on e3 would check
King to h2 Queen captures and he too
would check King to g1 and now pin to e3
and it's game over King to g2 and Bishop
to c4 check wins the Queen so after this
rook to g8 Carlsen first played King to
g2 we have f5 by von Schuch not really
caring about this H pawn so we have
Bishop captures on h5
and we have rooked rook C to F 8 we have
b5 proximate attacking on the Queen side
and we have F 4 if I took counter
attacking on the on the Kings side we
had it captures an F 4 and of course
Bishop captures on i-4 as the bishop
cannot be captured since it's protected
and it cannot be captured with the Jeep
on set since the pawn is pinned we have
a queen to e1 and here if I took sex the
bishop he plays Bishop captures and G 3
we have F captures and G 3 and here is
the most critical moment of the game if
I place rook to F 1 and as this is a
blitz game there both players were in a
huge time trouble only move for Carson
here is to capture this rook and this
would be a better position for black
even though Carson gives up the Queen
for two pieces although it's three
pieces and a magic already suck that
Bishop and g3 so this would be better
for revenge but it would be playable but
in this position Carson X actually
played Queen to d2 Queen to d2 and you
want to immediately jumps in with Queen
to g1 and as he played this Magnus
Carlsen immediately resigned and they
want to jump from the table as he was
exhilarated and how Magnus Carlsen
missed this move as well of course it's
game over after King to h3 after King to
h3 it's a row captures and g3 checkmate
but in this position Magnus Carlsen
resigned and like I said I will I will
put the video of this amazing jump by
Van choke in the description below and
also you can see how how very angry
Magnus Carlsen was for for missing this
mating idea and above the board you can
see his quote that he tweeted that he
can't win them all apparently and this
will seem to repeat every time Magnus
Carlsen faces even chokers in 2016 he
will lose both games he plays against
them so yeah definitely definitely a
world champions nightmare this vastly
valchek fellow so yeah this is the game
against course
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank a and the auto and truck repair
for a contribution to my channel I
really appreciate it thank you a lot and
yeah as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon